[Music]  following their closure due to covet 19  the smith center for performing arts is  returning with a big bang today  after 482 days president and ceo myron  martin  lit the ghost light in celebration the  non-profit also announced  a brand new broadway show coming to las  vegas first it's called  an officer and a gentleman on the  opening night  at the smith center we will represent  the world premiere of an officer and a  gentleman  and it makes us so happy well the lineup  for the 2021 2022 broadway las vegas  series includes cats  a christmas carol my fair lady the  band's  visit and tootsie all of those tickets  are on sale now at the smith center's  website  thesmithcenter.com